what's up taste buddies i am hitting the
road to do stand-up comedy finally i
haven't been out in a while all tickets
available at
savilecanocomedy.com right now i will be
in
uh fort lauderdale to dania uh improv uh
november 12th through the 14th i will be
in the west palm beach improv uh
december 4th and 5th i will be
uh at in boston in medford at the cheval
year i don't know if i'm saying that
right theater december 10th boston come
out you always come out big and then i'm
really excited about this one the
borgata in atlantic city new jersey i
performed there like so many times with
the guys never solo first one that's
gonna be a lot of fun uh where else we
going with this the week between
christmas and new year's eve december 26
dallas december 27 san antonio december
28th sugarland december 29th st louis
missouri december 30th column columbus
ohio and new year's eve in cincinnati
ohio all co-headlining with chrissy d
all tickets savile kennel comedy.com
right now
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking hey taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds look that thing's like
second nature at this it is now yeah
right yeah
it's like it's like the we are the
titans yeah yeah we uh
the titans no that's my friend
[Laughter]
we are the titans
that disney movie like we are the titans
i don't know something like that they
had some chance
i watched titans on dc
network
hbo max rather
the tv show titans about the superheroes
shows shout out the boys shout out to
boys got some friends on there oh yeah
karen yeah yeah we were kicking it with
jack yeah nice kid speaking of which
shout out to karen as well oh and karen
yes shout out to what we do in the
shadows uh absolutely kicking it with
our boy there it's time did i did i ever
mention i i have um doing a little guest
role i did okay yeah shout out to my boy
harvey on there harvey my man and all of
them they're they're just awesome
natasha everybody there yeah harvey uh
here's a funny story of course he dm me
the other day
he said
he said remember the park
where we ate joe's pizza because
remember that night we went out and got
joe's pizza and ate it of park
and i go yeah dude and i sent him a pin
on the map and i go it's right here if
you're looking for and he goes no i'm
saying remember when we ate pizza in the
park
and i was like
because it was only that was fun man and
he's like yeah
oh really
that's cool he's a good guy man great
guy i love that he reached out hello
uh speaking of great guys
we got a we got an arbiter here today
who was here in the last episode
as a the first one to challenge the
taste buds and he was here so he's
hanging out again to weigh in here and
there on this debate we're about to have
this fire debate this is wild
han solo versus luke skywalker
and i took han solo
i which i mentioned on the last step got
him you got that bug got him what are
those things
from the plants i have downstairs i had
one of those in my room last night it
bit me six times and i i was scratching
all night i think that's a mosquito it
kept flying in front of me like i could
see it because it would go past my
screen on my ipad yeah and i it kept me
awake that's how you get them by the way
oh showing me crazy this guy he
terrorized me the whole last episode i
was looking for him tell your friends
tell your friends
so what's gonna happen everybody the uh
the uh that was very on luke skywalker
like of you
well cause luke would believe i'm not
luke no one's luke luke is the only luke
there is no one's hot
hands on there all right well we have a
lot to talk about all right uh let's
bring out our arbiter uh ari shafir
arbiter shafir arbiter shafir coming out
of the toilet
he he has the mic
oh what sounds did you do on that thing
no were you doing sounds funny
i'm trying to keep it very quiet but you
did the other two
worst opportunity i just didn't yeah i
did a flush okay good good
um so today's taste bud uh battle is
not of the food variety you know that we
recently switched off here on there we
like to sprinkle them in there's more to
taste than just the tongue that's right
the taste you have that's a good line in
uh a galaxy far far away
and uh you said to me
i think luke versus han would be a great
one i was like holy [ __ ] that's amazing
and you said i'm taking han though
and i stopped because everyone likes han
the bad boy
and uh i said no
skywalker has enough stock for me to
take him and take you out okay so i took
skywalker yeah yeah well i mean
you're talking like skywalker is some
potential slouch this is not these are
the two guys these are them
these are the two guys the only other
the only the other the candidate would
be leia this is it this is this is your
three this is an age-old question right
yes yeah yes and i and i think the only
reason it's han and luke
and and it's the only reason
i can't talk the only reason it's
excluding leia is because we're going
back to the argument you had as kids
yeah and as two young boys from the
block right next to where jenny came
from right now
she just existed
she was a pawn
she didn't do anything she was upon him
and moved around she sent the original
message
sent a message oh help is the is what
she did
and she's up there attacking me and she
got it yeah she got help she got people
to bypass what they should have been
doing we blew up the death star baby and
guess who did that the best pilot in all
the galaxy on that x-wing leia luke
skywalker
she's luke's sister too she is luke's
sister on almost
and come on that when she was a prisoner
man that outfit is iconic all her
outfits are iconic but like
that's one of those things like wonder
woman when a gal
that you that you like
throws herself into that
yeah special treat
yeah yeah yeah that is a that is like a
fantasy sexual fantasy thing princess
leia
my profession shout out to the doe is
wonder woman
is how's wonder woman going to have a
flat booty
that's a good question that's a good
question that's a good point dude i i uh
i wonder what supposed to be an amazon
she's got to be a big curvy lady you
know she doesn't you you you could you
just you you
took me you watch the movie those metal
trunks are sliding off
i really hope i really hope the kid was
making music for us makes that a song
you heard it buddy go after it wait
patty jenkins the director of wonder
woman is a friend of mine
and i've been i've been i'm a fan of
patty jenkins and i've been on set for
wondering nothing to do
but she is she's she's stunning she's
she's gorgeous it's almost like you you
like it it's it's it's it's right i was
in something with her what's the same
thing are you like you you're like no it
doesn't make sense yeah it's like i
thought she was a good wonder woman too
yeah she's a wonder woman it's fun to
make little jokes and quips and japes
and jives speaking of little jokes
but but but patty jenkins right on topic
because she's directing the rogue one no
i'm sorry the uh rogue squadron movie oh
yeah which i'm very excited to see
um
well the wonderful patty jenkins shout
out patty jenkins shout out toddy
jenkins director of monster
yes yes what happened to the damn too
what happened to chance guys are we
gonna do the chance we didn't get to the
battle yet oh okay sorry this feels
badly yeah oh no no no no no
we're just kidding we're just getting
warmed up here we're just getting warmed
up but i mean are we going to let's get
into this i got a lot to say let's get
in why were you on the set of wonder
woman because i'm friends with patty
jenkins why are you friends with patty
jenkins i don't mean why like you
shouldn't be i mean how so okay so
my my lawyer who is a dear friend
is uh a childhood friends with her okay
and that she said she liked the show and
we were a fan of her and so do you want
to do the taste bud stuff for us no no
no different lawyer yeah my main like
entertainment who's that lawyer then
who's the lawyer we have for taste buds
a recommendation from my lawyer that's
specialized in trademarks so can your
lawyer get me on to the rogue squadron
set
and me make me friends with patty
jenkins i mean i could ask patty but can
i come to the rose squadron set if you
play cards right i'll ask do you think
she listens to the show do you think
she's going to hear the flat booty joke
i made well
it's not her booty
yeah she might i'll show you right now
i'll tell you right now
you're not getting on with that flat
booty talk
you think do you think patty would see
the humor in the joke yeah i do okay
she's really funny all right good all
right
uh han solo vs luke skywalker all right
here we go let's just start it cause i
got a lot to say
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you
here we go
b-a-t-t-l-e bunch
do you like the chance battle buds yeah
he brought the chance to the table like
four five six episodes ago i think
something like that maybe more i don't
know
his own and i said it really feels silly
but then we embrace the silliness but
then he when he came with no matter what
happens i love you that shattered the
glass ceiling oh wow
what are the what do the crowds say
about this they are they they they love
it they put in the comments oh they want
no matter what happens i love you merch
which is coming oh folks had a meeting
today we got some good merch coming out
man
it's in the works like we picked the
merch we picked what it's gonna be
there's gonna be hoodies t-shirts hats
socks laces stickers it's gonna be good
yeah they are we finalized merch you
have good merch actually you have really
good ones yeah i like making it like
cool to wear yeah
do a little merch shout out you do you
great uh you go to rshafir.com you get
merch as a alice in wonderland ari uh
and uh shroomfest shirts if you're uh
that's not for this show you also have
paraffin like marijuana paraphernalia or
some [ __ ] i used to have grinders
yeah yeah and uh yeah all sorts of cool
t-shirts tour shirts really instead of
just like here's what i'm saying that's
awesome i like it where'd you get the
delirious shirt
oh i was at the concert when i was
younger my mom and dad took me you're
joking no and it was like yeah and they
got me the shirt
is
he's completely lying right now i was
too young but it was what do you mean do
you want me to quote the jokes sometimes
though you know a woman they'll kick you
out of the car if i remember it's a long
time ago this is clearly a screen the
silkscreen t-shirt is it your dad you
got off the internet he's mine oh he was
not at the show okay in fairness okay
in fairness
we got the bootleg version outside uh
instead of the overpriced version inside
and then my dad was like this will fade
so don't wash it and i haven't yeah okay
and he was like you know they were
making boot like t-shirts in 83 like
that yeah he was like you'll grow into
it when you're in your 40s
but it still looks brand new yeah that's
incredible i'm a hoarder
all right listen
i mean we could talk star wars all day
you're going to and babe i could but
i'll tell you this right now
uh when i was a little child
luke was my guy when i was a young boy
why is it because when you're a little
kid you want to be the farm boy that
becomes the prince that swings the sword
and has the magic and knows the wizard
and all these things but then you get a
little i wish i knew you as a pre i wish
i knew you as a preteen i think you
should try to do a cartoon on yourself
with you as a preteen
i'm telling you i want to see that
derosa
i want to see that one who is like who
longed for to swing a sword
which one of us in this room has the
ability to get that done
let's make it sal okay i'm sitting here
i'm selling
hoagies
please
oh my god
i'm sorry for all the coughing i still
have a cold
i can see derosa
oh if i could have had a nanny cam in
that room it's dark
it's dark i used to stare out at a uh
this is a true story and then we'll move
on
we had we had a ditch next to our house
like a big ditch
i mean a ditch it was just a ditch like
it was like they they'd since like put
grass in it like or whatever but it was
like this big ditch i guess it was like
so for like runoff like water runoff in
the neighborhood and stuff
but we and and i hated my neighborhood
so much and i would sit down
sit out and just stare into the ditch in
the cold
when i was in third grade i just sit up
what that's the story
that you looked at the ditch i would
stare into it for hours what were you
hoping come out like pan's labyrinth
there was nothing to do dude it was it
was i was what i would argue
i would argue a peak depression time in
my life third grade there was nothing oh
my god i would argue i would argue that
i swear i'm sweaty i'm not trying to be
funny i would that's so sad
it wasn't very sad i went to catholic
school i hated it my school was really
small there was just no adventure i was
like a lot like luke i was staring out
of the two suns saying there's gotta be
something better for me out there wow
and i would stare into this ditch
that's that's unbelievable oh you raised
in solitary confinement
that's what it takes no you could have
stared at a host of other things that's
sad you don't see where i grew up there
were nothing else to stare at philly
west philadelphia born and raised
collegeville suburbs wow
i was underdeveloped at the time did
your parents not get you like a bowl or
something
yeah but i gotta tell you dude you can
only play with toy like i had friends
obviously but like wait wait wait wait
you're gonna tell me you can only play
with toys so much and in the next
session
you're gonna say the ditch has a
three-hour run time right
you can only play with toys so much by
yourself before you just get like you're
just like but why just staring to a dick
did you look around do you have your
choice what was something going on in
your imagination in the ditch no it
would be like it'd be like there'd be
days where like after school and i was
miserable because i hated it it'd be
cold outside and nobody could play
you know none of my friends could play
and i would just go sit i had no
siblings and i would just go sit and
just like sit by this ditch because i
was like i guess this is like a thing to
do it's sort of on our property
that's sad yeah
i would have maybe maybe we would go
because it was a good start i thought
you were gonna at least say you rolled
around a ditch you took some tonka
trucks you rolled them down and up the
ditch you just stared at me there was a
little creak in it that i fell in once
or twice
wait a minute how long did your
relationship with the ditch go on
that ditch was a huge part of my
childhood
but like it was a part of our childhood
i wasn't the only one with the ditch i
feel like if he went back to see the
ditch now he would collapse like he just
heard it came back
it was like the giving tree the [ __ ]
was like i was here to make you a man
when did you finally ditch it oh jesus
will you like ditch please
please
son of a [ __ ] um anyway
i got a little bit older and my point is
is once i got a little bit older i'm
talking 11. next tastebuds
[Music]
han solo how are you even messing with
han solo dude he's the coolest guy in
the galaxy he's the coolest guy that's
ever lived it's harrison ford incarnate
it's like there's nothing
harrison ford could only outdo harrison
ford with indiana jones like it's it's
han
solo i can't tell you something bruv
cool will only get you so far really
then you gotta find someone to save the
entire galaxy how about the last person
is the chosen one the chosen sun the
last jedi that's luke skywalker right
let's just go from every single part of
it by the way we're focusing we forgot
to mention we're focusing on main
trilogy main trilogy originally trilogy
that's okay
yeah
because what happens in the later ones
both their deaths are kind of like
disappointing hans is not he just gives
himself up but it's to his son for the
love of his son it's a beautiful moment
but we're not doing sex okay okay right
now all right let's start with the name
let's just start with the name on paper
luke
skywalker han solo you want to talk cool
that's one of the coolest names i've
ever heard in my entire life han solo is
cool doesn't hold a candle to luke
skywalker your name here's the thing
your name
a movie name
luke skywalker is a cool movie name or
cool storybook name your name could be
han solo in real life and people would
be like holy [ __ ] your name is awesome
if your name was luke skywalker in real
life they would not say the same thing
goofy they would say the same exact
thing
thank you
arbitrator i never thought of that but
on name luke skywalker is better and
also that comes to mind uh there's a
weed named after skywalker there is no
solo weed much like
well come on dude there's a weed that
there's come on that's don't break
true 100 skywalker og's cool yeah yeah
skywalker og's the coolest weed name
ever next to klingon uh there's klingon
it's not han oh gee that's not good okay
so because because han is more of a
whiskey guy and we all know it han sits
back with his feet up and he drinks some
blue milk
all right yeah let's talk outfits let's
talk you can't don't even try
this oh my god
look at the picture there's no question
on that no no no i'm not talking that
outfit babe that outfit
solo
outfit he wears pull up jedi luke please
with the hood on because it's the best
outfit i've ever seen in my life it's
couture that's not the only okay with
the hood up babe if somebody walked down
a runway in today's day and age and
during fashion week in new york city in
that thing with the hood on that [ __ ]
would sell off the shelves kane would be
in that right now i want i want empire
han outfit that is not the only outfit
han has
empire han outfit you could roll into
any bar in new york with this on look at
this oh come on
[Music]
i don't know about compared to hurricane
but on its own he could be in the
strokes yes exactly he looks like
han solo is wearing an alpha from
structure that's what he's wearing i
swear to god he's wearing an outfit he's
got a gun
strapped to his leg bro i mean he's a
ninja luke skywalker looks like a ninja
in that black looks like clint eastwood
that looks like the baddest outlaw of
all time what are we talking about
han by default comes with chewie you get
chewy with that chewy
he couldn't have strawberries in his
cheerios now you want to add a full
character you want to add a wookie it's
not two on one otherwise you're getting
r2d2 and c3po all right fine fine all
right fine no i'll give you i'll give
you r2 as as as luke's sidekick we're
not doing a tag team match it's not even
in the poll
stop diverting all right by the way i
went to versus the other night at the
barclay krs1 vs big daddy kane oh that's
cool
that's
it was sunday you told me you were sick
you told me on sunday you didn't know if
you could
i don't think we should have done this
this guy's hacking up [ __ ] phlegm all
over the place today fair gnats are in
here waiting for the carcass fair but
you could have told me you were going to
that it would have been like hey are you
too sick to go it might be the best show
i've ever seen in my own time are you
serious yeah but anyway i bring it up
because because
kate capri was krs once dj and dj
scratch was big daddy cage dj and dj
scrap kept trying to challenge kid capri
to a scratch-off
because it's in the name capri's a party
dj scratch is more of a scratch
and
and keras one goes
ain't nobody
because ain't nobody don't nobody want
to hear from you scratch
i ain't here to battle you
and uh he goes y'all are running out of
songs but it's all played it's all
playful yeah it was great and the place
is going
yeah and then he dropped love's gonna
get you and he's going nothing but
classics
they were both great but keras ripped
that place to the to the ground yeah
while west must have been in our minds
well das effects came out they did know
what they were you want to fix no uh
craig g and master ace came out they did
the symphony with big daddy kane did dos
effects nail it uh nice and smooth came
out they did dwick yeah it was awesome
dwig is arguably the greatest hip-hop
song of all time awesome it was awesome
all right so that anyway i'm just saying
that because the sidekick thing i'm
sorry okay back to the battle this
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
man if you listen to the podcast itself
and not the ads we throw around the name
betterhelp all the time because we love
it is there something interfering with
your happiness preventing you from
achieving your goals uh i don't know i
mean i i get down i get listless you
know i i i mean coming out of this
pandemic it's been tough it's been tough
for a lot of people this is a really
cool thing that you can use to help you
better help not health we'll assess your
needs and match you with a licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating with them within two days
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not even self-help it is
professional counseling it's done
securely online so you don't have to
leave your house they have experts all
over from many areas so if you didn't
have one that was close to you you need
a certain type of expert you will have
that clients are worldwide
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available betterhelp wants to start
living a happier life today they want
you to start living a happier life today
uh visit the website read the
testimonials i did it and they are rave
reviews betterhelp.comslash reviews so
this is what you're gonna do if you want
to
uh
check out betterhelp go to
betterhelp.com tastebuds that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join over a million people who have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
if you've been hesitant too
to make a phone call to go sit with
someone in person you know if that's not
your thing if that's the thing that's
been holding you back this is this is
for you so many people have been using
betterhelp that they're recruiting and
additional counselors in all the 50
states special offer for our listeners
taste buds get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com
taste buds that's 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
tastebuds
what's up guys want to talk to you about
butcher box butcher box is a meat
subscription service which sounds funny
but it has changed my life be prepared
for whatever life throws your way with a
high quality meat delivered right to
your dough
each box has 9 to 11 pounds of meat if
you're choosing so you order this thing
once you throw it in the freezer and
then you don't think about it again
until it runs out and they have
everything they have grass-fed beef they
have organic free-range chicken humanely
raised pork wild caught lobster tails
alaskan salmon wild caught and then this
other thing sugar-free bacon that's
that's been rocking my world lately and
for a limited time they are giving uh
members right now new members
ground beef to the tune of two pounds
free that's insane they're going to send
you two pounds or you're gonna have you
could feed your family for free on that
one um
it's easy to sign up right you just
choose your box you choose your
frequency that you want it to come to
your house they offer five different
types so you can customize one or go
with their four curated ones so you get
exactly what you want it ships to order
at its peak freshness when it comes they
freeze it i have not had uh any meat
that i got from them that did not
taste
amazing right on that's it's good it's
packed in 100 recyclable stuff and the
shipping is always free so that's good
um yeah that's what i do i i go wild on
the lobster tails
i uh i don't know i just because it's
like you know i mean i i love this
especially with all the meat prices
skyrocketing yeah in the supermarket a
lot right now because everything yeah
and another thing is like i don't want
to go and get a lobster and then i have
to just spear at a throw in the pot
myself but i love lobster so i go with
that this is your chance to never have
to shop for ground beef again that's
right oh it's two pounds of ground beef
sorry for life
that's that's a big thing i forgot to
say for life um so this is your chance
never shop for ground beef again you
don't want to do that that's right
butcher box is giving new members free
ground beef for life sign up at
butcherbox.com taste buds get that two
pounds of that beef free in every order
that you make for the life of your
membership so you're never paying for
that again log on to butcherbox.com
taste buds to claim this deal ready i
mean
but by the way at verses i was like this
is kind of like taste buds
they stole the idea from you they
probably did
but you know what no seriously though
it's like taste buds hip-hop street beef
yeah
yeah carrots was like no no no no no no
no
yeah
yeah uh look at han right there let's
let's go i just got to tell you luke
skywalker is the last jedi he trained
with yoda he picked the x-wing out of
the goddamn swamp no he didn't he
couldn't do it he couldn't do it he
couldn't do it till sequel trilogy no
yeah but he couldn't do it no he
couldn't who did it arguing trilogy all
right fine if you're and if you're going
to talk original trilogy
luke said
[Laughter]
luke says and i quote
oh luke says yoda pulls it out and luke
says i can't believe it and yoda says
and that is why you fail
that's what happens with the uh i can't
believe it does swallow what's the
swamps uh dagobah yeah yeah
you want to talk badass moves don't talk
badass moves yeah han's best buddy
outside of chewie
what did he just do no nothing nothing
no he went and got walled off in statler
oh that's a great that's a great image
for me and you yeah to be those two guys
that you check out their opinions of the
best thing yes i think one of the fans
did one really i think oh that's great
that was burt and ernie we did bernard
but we got a ton of
we've got to do those anyway
you want to talk badass moves han's best
friend outside of chewie lando betrays
him
han walks without batting an eye
like much like ari shafir doing the chip
challenge
into freezing and carbonite
i was going to get going i was i was
going to get going into this boy's
frozen he's inconsequential he go
he's he's about to face death he tells
you he's taken
from the carbonite oh yeah no you're
talking about going into the
you're talking about the attitude going
into the carbonite his attitude going in
she goes i love you and he goes i know
it's the baddest most baddest ass you
want
in movie hit
indiana jones shooting the swordsman
hold on that's the baddest thing in
movie in in movie history or at least in
the star wars universe you think that's
the baddest thing i think that is the
most badass thing ever in a movie ever i
got something to say what's badass
okay
take your little toy ray gun and shove
it up your ass
really this
is the coolest thing in cinematic
history certainly in the star wars
universe i'll tell you what i got a
lightsaber bruv can't do anything about
that this is the best thing this is this
is the epitome of star wars this is the
representation of star wars and this is
what luke's
that's right i respect the lightsaber
you gotta you gotta you're gonna you've
got a reagan guess who has a ray gun
every guard in the galaxy okay well
guess what nothing but guess what well
guess what
guess what
i'll slice you in half with this with
little effort take your little
okay i'll tell you what
take your little x-wing
my little x-wing okay with your little
bubble-headed one in the background
that destroyed the death star and come
the one that
greatest pilot in the galaxy i flew into
an asteroid field on purpose to elude
tie fighters and they couldn't touch me
i love the millennium no one doesn't
there's no one that doesn't i can't say
nothing about it yeah the falcon that
saved your ass when they left you on
that weather antenna
in cloud city i'm sorry
is han solo dn like the falcon is one
thing han solo is another thing no
that's hans it's just it's just it's his
car okay it's just fine fine fine i mean
you're going to bring up lightsabers i'm
bringing up
yeah okay thank you rory thank you also
another iconic moment in movies is when
he goes
hey i'm turning off the [ __ ] device
i'm gonna go solo on this
that's luke i know and it was a cool
moment that's right and i'll tell you
another force babe not only did he
destroy the death star
he killed darth vader in a lightsaber
battle he didn't kill darth vader what
do you mean darth vader dies from the
from the wounds he he gets from the
emperor
the lightning wounds
that's what darth vader that's what
kills vader's but the betrayal the
emperor and the lightning going into
vader's body luke beats up on him pretty
good but that's not what i mean it was a
contributing factor
uh yeah i mean sure he what do you mean
he got the upper hand he did it
no
vader dies because he betrays the
emperor i understand that and gets
lightning but and by the way luke is
dead
vader saves his he wasn't in that
position he wouldn't have been in that
position if it wasn't for luke though
vader stands up next to the emperor
while the emperor lights up luke with
the lightning and then vader saves luke
sure vader saves luke and then feels bad
and it by and it feels bad he picks up
what about badass luke losing a goddamn
hand okay and then coming back with a
bionic goddamn hand i mean who cares
losing a limb in that universe means
nothing because they could just build
you a new one that looks normal who
cares right
pimp am i wrong you could get one of
those in this universe
it's dramatic he's hanging there he's
gonna die he's got one hand he comes
back and he said he's saves the guy
i'll tell you something that han's never
done that luke does speaking of that
specific scene and i can name a few
other scenes han has never whined
god luke whines
but i wanted to go to tashi station to
pick up some power converters i'll never
get off this rock oh that droid's going
to cause me a lot of trouble you're
right
you're right
you're right you're right luke
skywalker's your soul mates
i can't believe you're not arguing for
him han starts at a level of nine and
stays there whereas luke starts at a
dork and moves up to where he is yeah
but i like that i like an arc i like
progression
around getting odd jobs shooting people
first is there anybody
is there anybody
cooler than when han solo is barking
orders at people
when he's going joey are you screaming
everybody did anybody say sweetheart
smoother than han solo but it does and
it weirdly doesn't sound sexist what he
says is so cool
i'll tell you but all he's got all he's
got though in the ways of fighting
is peeking out from the side of a
doorway and going
and then ducking back in that's his
contribution yeah
this guy he's crazy this guy's walking
down a hallway just turning people into
robes that fall on the floor he's just
lighting people up he's cleaning him
like butter he's never done that once oh
he did in the latest ones no he never
did he never killed anybody with his
legs they had him as a as a cgi and he
walked in and just sliced everybody up i
think in the mandalorian mandalorian all
right i watched it it was wrong
it was robots babe it was robots he was
slicing through lucas never slows
through one person robots that nobody
else could defeat at all that posed
never sliced through one human being
with his
lightsaber han has shot
many human storm troopers han also was a
defector from the empire which is
awesome
who which one of them lived in
damn which one of them lived inside a
[ __ ] giant cow
han oh
oh
thank you
han solo saved your ass again you need
to be saved you're gonna freeze to death
after the wampa attack on hoth han
slices over the open the taunton and
puts you inside he's the one he saves
luke i gave you my sister oh please i
gave you my sister on a platter please
you're my friend you're not supposed to
my best friend's not supposed to go bang
my sister i gave her to you i was like
it's cool i we can still have a
friendship and you can still be in love
with my
your sister's knees were wobbling when i
walked through the door
watch your mouth when you talk about
leia like that yeah yeah your sister's
sneaking out of her bedroom window to
meet me behind the barn you know very
well
you need to worry about that
you needed luke's blessing and and he
remained best friends with you despite
the fact
brought up han was better at cynicism
luke was better at idealism this is ham
is better spontaneity luke was better
with a plan i agree with all those
statements i will say this and this is
what i love so much about heart i think
han
if you were going to apply their
perspectives to real life okay their
perspectives not their abilities nothing
else just their attitude towards
the the world they lived in
i think hans attitude even is so much
better i think it's so much more
commendable a guy that's like it's all
[ __ ] i'm not getting involved your
idealism is fake it's going to fall it's
not it's why is that guy amazing the guy
the guy that's doing everything to the
wind and doesn't give a goddamn to me
versus the guy who's who steps up and
saves everyone's life
luke to me is uh luke's looks like a
twitter sjw you know what i mean like i
i was offended by that i was like give
me a break
he is a jedi
end of story yeah he's a jedi
han solo is a work for hire mechanic how
dare you how dare you he's a smuggler
he's a scoundrel yeah these are two of
the coolest words on earth already to
describe it
there are a lot of jedi there's only one
no there's a lot of smugglers too no
that's not true there's one han solo you
could pick it i'm sure there are other
smugglers in that universe but have we
ever heard of one you could pick it up
from that handle that a scoundrel is
cool but i mean at the end of the day
he's a scoundrel and one is the hero the
actual hero
you couldn't have done [ __ ] on that that
by the way that death star you were
going to die on it but han was down on
it
bringing down the the the um
the shield that's a good point if not
for han solo there luke doesn't even get
a shot off yeah look they they helped
each other by the way
how about this line who said this line
who said this slide
that's two you own me junior
han solo why because he saves his life
at the beginning of empire and he knocks
out vader's tie fighter in the death
star trench so luke can get his shot off
on the on the death star he's arrogant
he might be clue cool but he's also an
arrogant [ __ ] yeah you wish there was
some more humility from hunting yeah and
he gets princess leia she's a princess
in the head of the rebellion founder of
the new republic he gets her gals like
bad boys oh come on he's a bad boy yeah
i bet i bet n i don't know if there's a
positive or negative i bet uh han solo
tried anal with princess leia
[Laughter]
and i had and luke had no problem with
it
yeah all right guys we got a new sponsor
on board called quip you may have heard
of them i actually have owned quip for
years already so it's cool to have them
there uh quip is uh basically i have the
toothbrush which is it looks like a
regular toothbrush it's the regular size
of a toothbrush but it actually vibrates
and it gives you like completely better
brushing so i use
a bigger toothbrush at home but when i
travel on the road for comedy i don't
want to lug that big thing and it's got
to be like charged on a battery holder
so i take my equipment with me all the
time on the road and i actually i
actually love it
good health starts with good habits quit
makes it easy by delivering all the oral
care essentials you need to care for
your mouth right to your door the quip
electronic toothbrushes which i got is
loved by over seven million miles um
this is some features time sonic
vibrations with 30 second pulses to
guide a dentist recommended two minute
clean so you hit it and it'll vibrate
and you know to do the top left until it
stops and then you do the top right and
so it's kind of like lets you know that
you have to
you know you gotta some people just
brush them out really quick and they
just throw it out and those people
you know who wants to kiss those people
a lightweight and sleek design for
adults and kids with no wires bulky
charger to weigh you down i didn't even
read that and i said it a multi-use
travel cover that doubles as a mere
amount for less clutter they also
send other things beside the
toothbrushes they have an anti-cavity
toothpaste they have two flavors mint
and watermelon prevents cavities they
got a refillable mouthwash that's four
times concentrate so it's good for you
and since it's refillable you're helping
the planet in addition to brush heads
they deliver also floss toothpaste
mouthwash gum refills every three months
for five bucks shipping is free you can
save money and skip the hustle and
bustle of in-store shopping with stylish
and affordable electron electric brushes
starting at just 25 bucks you won't be
paying through the teeth for better oral
health if you go to get quip dot com
slash taste buds right now you'll get
your first refill free that's your first
refill free at get quip dot com slash
taste buds g-e-t
q-u-i-p dot com slash taste buds quip
the good habits company
harry's harry's harry's have you looked
in the mirror recently have you really
looked guys we're coming out of a
pandemic we're coming out of a
quarantine situation people starting
going back to the office i had my
longest beard in my life uh during this
thing me too yeah i grew it out i said
why not right but i am sick and tired of
it i trimmed it up now but i still use
my harry's razor to get like all this
and all the the stuff that doesn't come
in well you have the best beard i've
ever seen
i would trade my i would pay for your
beard
your beard is the beard i wish i had
i'm true it's true i only like it
because it doesn't match the rest of my
hair
oh yeah it is it's like red yeah you're
right it's sharp man it's all harry's
yeah harry's you know harry's they they
are great razors uh because harry's
insists you shouldn't have to choose
between a great shave and a fair price
to give you both refill blades are a
start as low as two bucks that's easy
peasy i mean any of the refill blades in
the store cost way more than that even
easier new harry's customers get their
starter set which includes a five blade
razor weighted handle which i like i
like that the handle has weight to it
when i'm in the shower because like just
those little chintzy plastic ones
there's just nothing to them it feels
like you know what i mean i don't know
just a better experience it's a better
ergonomic experience um you get the way
to handle the foaming shave gel with
aloe which is awesome it's so smooth and
a travel cover for 30 it's a 13 value
you get it for three dollars
um they sent me one but i already had
one because i've been using harry's for
a while i really like it i just keep my
little thing in the shower and a little
cup and i hit hit it up boom boom boom
like whoa five blades i go one time when
you get the two blades you gotta be like
dude
i can find blade they just go one time
what do you want me to tell you i i'm
usually in a rush so that's good there's
never been a better time to try harry's
go to harrys.com tastebuds to get their
starter set for just three beans uh it's
a hundred percent satisfaction
guaranteed you got nothing to lose go to
harry's dot com slash taste buds right
now to get this special offer that's
h-a-r-r-y-s dot com slash taste buds
what did he what did he call it he
called it oh my god his real okay han
solo's real name is hanzo organa no way
his name is hanzel bro
no long-lost son of bile organic no bail
or no
that is that is completely wrong bail
organa is leia's father tan is not the
son of baal organa his name is not han
that's wrong whatever it is
i don't know what that is
what is hanzo's really that's lurking
that's wrong that's just not what his
name is then what is his name claire
mcnair
is just a mishearing of the abbreviated
name hansel oh hansel oh
in reality hansel o is
is leia's father that
it's not han's father adopted brother
well it's on the internet yeah so it
must be who's claire mcnair
this is also by the way this is coming
from a story interviewing ansel egert
who played solo in the solo movie and in
the solo movie they've established his
name as han solo
so you know ben's name his son is ben
solo it's not ben organa
hansel oh fix yeah no come on this is
we're wikipedia that's the one yeah
let's see yeah
look in in star wars lore and in the
fandom
do me a favor go
yeah he's awesome now go to the
wikipedia picture of luke skywalker
let's just a b this bim
let's just say be this
dude i come on pimp pimp can you put
them side by side on the wall here but
you you're picking you're picking an
outfit that i don't the wiki pictures
yeah but you're picking the outfit
but you're hand picking the outfit
you're cherry picking the outfit
versus letting letting me pick the
outfit that goes against it no i said
just go to the luke skywalker wikipedia
skywalker's jedi outfit is the best
outfit that's for all the stars i'm just
saying just go to the default wikipedia
picture what does that prove joe it's
just
the wiki page save that as a jpeg any
random picture you
do you think disney's not involved in
the wikipedia pages about star wars
characters no i don't own the brand you
think no okay wiki is isn't it wiki
then i'll broaden the argument to this
the whole point of wikipedia is that it
is not difficult any random picture
you go to any random picture of of uh
han solo but you're choosing that outfit
for him
[Music]
yeah that's the outfit that he always
wears so you have no choice but to use
that outfit whereas luke does different
outfits i'm not sure the argument is
even supposed to be the argument is this
luke has a pretty dope ass x-wing too
they see them both in stormtrooper
outfits no this is the argument this is
the argument
the argument is go
randomly to a picture of luke versus a
picture of how he picks him up
nine times out of ten the random picture
of han han will look cooler than the
random picture of luke
you have to seek out a picture of luke
looking cool argument that is so let's
see how they both look at this it's not
stupid that is such a stupid argument
about who is cooler
i'm not choosing it talking about cooler
pick the coolest outfit in the whole
universe which is his jedi album no it's
not i'm sorry
cloak when did you get that how do you
get to that i am saying any random
picture you go to if han solo versus any
random picture you go to of luke no
matter what the outfit is han is going
to look cooler that's what i'm saying
you're wrong he does wear that outfit
luke does wear that
a lot of it go back and go he wears it
in star wars in the jedi he wears the
black one
he wears he has his he has his orange
x-wing outfit his pilot outfit he has
his hoth outfit right he wears a he
wears a
uh you're looking at the one with like
the origin story where he lives on a
goddamn farm with his but his was an
uncle it's the picture on wikipedia
oh
my god
do me a favor i've argued this why would
i do this
google han solo
i know it bothered you
just google han solo no outside this is
my point hold on hold on hold on let me
just keep an argument no no no no no
nothing
[Music]
the coolest version of solo is not
better than the coolest version of luke
you're nuts with the with the green
light the jedi lightsaber and the cloak
hold on can i just do the thing i'm
trying to do please
i want you to a b this and we're going
to use zarya's the judge that one right
there baby stop
let me finish
jesus
pam go back to the go i want to a b han
solo and luke images this is so sweet
it's not stupid it's true because you're
going to lose
ari we're going to go through the first
it only has the one outfit but we're
going to go through the first 10 images
yeah okay i just want you to image the
image to go does he look cool or does he
not look cool okay that's it you're
ready yeah he's [ __ ] he's you know
from limited for number one cool number
two cool same outfit number three cool
i mean these are all the same outfits it
doesn't matter it's about
look at that top right left right you
get that out here's that target
what are the guys
swear to god do you get that target look
at the shirt it's a white handle
you get a target it is also you're right
it's a fishing outfit does target have a
jedi cloak in any aisle no we're not
talking about the clothing you dumb [ __ ]
we're talking about if the guy looks
cool or not as a guy
jesus
just let me finish this i can't pull up
a cool a cool photo of luke skywalker
we're doing it in a second okay all
right
god damn it
go ahead
cool yeah it's all cool the same outfit
it's all cool
that's ten in a row cool now go to the
google search now do you go through the
first ten and just tell me if he looks
cool or not not cool headshot cool old
very cool bottom left right there baby
very cool the jam he
right there but i won is the point i'll
tell you what i'd rather i'll tell you
what i picture
the point you know what i define cool
you are who you are
he's falling over every everyone knows
that cool is being yourself to the hilt
even if you're a nerd if you're you if
you rock what who you are
you're cool
i'd rather see his journey from nerd to
freaking
king yeah then then you guys just
traipsed around all day and is in his
members only okay
he's wearing you guys wearing khakis
booty's on what are you talking about
all right anyway what if you hung out
with han solo and luckily just in
general you hung out with them well i'd
rather hang out
exactly that's my point at what point do
you go
to your friends hey does han wear the
same [ __ ] outfit
they make a joke about that in force
awakens really when leia when he and
leigh get reunited there's no dry
cleaning in the galaxy no when laying
him no no they actually make a dry
killing joke in last jedi which is why
ryan johnson sucks but anyway um
he they do a joke
when leia first sees on again after it's
been like many years
she goes she goes same jacket and he
goes no it's different and he like
points to like a little
like a little nothing like a flare on it
but they actually make that joke of like
you're already all right let's go to the
phones we got to wrap this up um
you want to read some comments i feel
like i read all right here's one here
let me get one han solo is a badass
smugglers from uh five uh oh spelled the
event shaven fold away number five han
solo is a badass smuggler luke kissed
his sister enough said enough said yeah
that implies that luke is way cooler
sister
hold on luke luke restarted the jedi
order han smuggled drugs
that's the winner
man that was a curveball i didn't see
that coming
[Laughter]
jake smith han solo is only good for
answering the question what's
masturbation called
in the star wars universe all right uh
i don't know okay um han solo all luke
did was whine like a baby in all three
original movies plus his character is
terrible in the new movies [ __ ]
which is a great point if you were to
bring the new movies into it han's
character is still awesome he gets a
great they get one great movie with han
han solo because older men are just
heart sized
no wait flip show that i want already to
see that watch that
when he shoots oh they they edited it
never mind it's that's not what oh it
looks like he's shot but he does shoot a
storm trooper without looking jar jar
binks beats some bones shut up block her
she's banned forever
where my
virgin's head
since i currently live in alabama i have
to pick the character that made out with
his twin sister it's another thing all
right that might be the winner
go ahead uh let's see
joe is han solo because he couldn't even
tell his best friend that he loved him
back so if sally babes is skywalker luke
wins
han
i knew this at the top the people that
that enjoy the star wars universe always
always pick han so
i'm honestly if you're going on coolness
it's han for sure yeah but all right
it's not about coolness it's not like
what could you live without and since he
was the chosen one
the poll was phrased choose
one okay who do you want in your corner
right one line in my corner no way this
is follow at this ryan hinton this ryan
hinton on twitter he wins with his son
uh kissed his sister tweet go ahead pimp
and uh
let's do a refresh and han's gonna win
it wow low votes today on this well we
did it fast okay seven thousand votes
right now
oh wait wait wait anybody got plugs i'm
gonna go yeah i'm guessing that han solo
runs away with this according to the
according to the the comments yeah han
solo creamed me yeah i'm in desperate
need of a win too so yeah
also said han solo cream to me yeah
that's nice is that your plug yeah i'll
be at the boston at the wilbur theater
december 9th uh i got uh in november i
got tampon orlando and in december i got
oklahoma city boston and uh uh
uh san antonio uh denver's coming up
everything is available at respear.com
my youtube
youtube.com where you can take yoga
classes taught by the only true yogi on
the internet yogi alright i will just
plug uh we'll see you in hell my other
podcasts get new episodes of patreon.com
wsyih podcast we'll see you in hell this
is november 15th yeah i know and then
follow me on instagram and twitter at
joe derosa comedy all right i'm at the
west palm beach improv december 4th and
5th i'm at the chevrolet theater in
medford which is right outside of boston
on december 10th uh the borgata events
center atlantic city on december 11th
and then that week in between christmas
and new year's it's dallas it's houston
it's san antonio st louis uh columbus
and cincinnati everything is available
right now on salvolcanocomedy.com
here we go
[Music]
oh my god 7 200 votes humble pie pim put
up this percentages no way it was
another two nail biters in a row
51.
wow yeah
51.3 percent
goes
to the the only jedi luke skywalker to
48.7 at han solo according to the
comments i thought it was gonna be like
an eighty-two that's what i thought too
i mean it was a narrow margin which i
get they're both good i think when luke
skywalker fans are a lot like skywalker
and they're meek but mighty
look dude it says choose one and the
bottom line is you've got someone to
have your back it's got to be the jedi
it's got to be i don't like the way you
worded that now now i have a problem
with the wording but that's not what we
do what we do around here so
[Laughter]
i still love you babe i love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste bud